it was the streak seen across the sky
now seen around the world this is our 8
news now investigators confirmed Metro
actually set up cameras at this home
where a family called 9-1-1 claiming to
see aliens in their backyard and tonight
a fierce debate is underway about the
legitimacy of an alleged UFO crash good
evening I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian
Loftus R8 news now investigators
reporting about terrified members of a
local family who told police they had
aliens in their backyard Chief
investigator George Knapp here to piece
it all together you know as with all
things UFO the public debate is
ferocious and ongoing was it all a hoax
where we duped was it all an evil plot a
cover-up all of the above we took
another look at the hubbub to separate
wheat from chaff
the fireball captured on a police body
cam on the night of April 30th was real
the American meteor society says
Witnesses reported seeing it all across
the west from Northeastern Utah to
Southern California another Las Vegas
resident sent us a video of the same
object recorded on her home camera
investigation by next star station klas
as the story of the Las Vegas incident
spread across newscasts and social media
one of NASA's planetary defense officers
weighed in to say it was likely a small
meteor that fell to Earth hundreds of
miles away from Las Vegas Police Videos
obtained by 8 news now indicate Metro
officers were among the witnesses one of
my partners said
too so that's why I'm kind of curious
the appearance of the meteor seemingly
triggered the events that followed a
frightened family called 9-1-1 and told
police they had 10 foot tall alien
beings in their backyard officers
responded to the home minutes later
interviewed the witnesses canvassed the
area and cautiously inspected the
backyard to look for intruders one thing
noticed by the officers was a circle in
the soil in conversations with us and in
a podcast interview Angel the main
witness suggested the circle might have
been created when an unknown object
landed in the yard social media sleuths
have since pointed out that the circular
image has been viewable via Google Earth
for more than a year the family told us
by phone they had seen suspicious
vehicles with Men In Black types
checking out their home turns out there
is substance to that a retired police
officer fessed up on news nation that he
spent days staking out the house to see
what if anything unfolded what about
those reports that Metro and installed a
special surveillance camera Atop The
House presumably to watch for intruders
human or otherwise or overzealous media
turns out that's true as well Metro
confirmed as much in a statement to
eight news now's David charns the system
stayed on the roof for days what about
the ring camera video with the weird
noise the main witness Angel intimated
to us the video was recorded by one of
his neighbors and the audio was from the
April 30th UFO crash it wasn't the
security camera video was recorded in
mid-april according to the man who first
posted the clip he doesn't want his name
used but says the recording was from a
fireball that passed over his home in
the southwestern part of the valley two
weeks prior to the alleged Alien
Encounter the family declined to be
interviewed by us but members have
spoken elsewhere and stick to their
claims of seeing aliens in the backyard
dozens of people on social media have
analyzed and dissected the images with
various claims of alien spotted in the
shadows police do not believe this was a
hoax call which could be a crime if done
intentionally in the fervid swamp known
as UFO World our coverage of the story
was itself seen as a dastardly plot to
distract the tension away from a
prominent whistleblower named David
grush who stepped forward around the
same time grosh unveiled his explosive
on-camera account on news nation which
is owned by the parent company of klas
in spite of the local news story
Russia's story was reported by news
media all over the world curses foiled
again
all right so I mean so what do you make
of this whistleblower David Rush he
first reached out to me about a year ago
we've been in contact ever since he's
the real deal I mean he had a
distinguished career in the Air Force
then he went to work for a three-letter
agency you probably haven't heard of the
NGA which basically tracks everything in
space in the air in the ocean under the
ocean on land they they keep tracks of
everything he has the highest security
clearances in our government and in that
capacity he interacted with something
like 2 000 sap special access programs
and he learned along the way that we've
got we're reverse engineering crash
flying saucers and he's been telling
that to Congress under oath behind
closed doors and I think they'll
probably bring him back so it's a pretty
intriguing story a lot like what we've
been hearing about out in the Nevada
desert for a long time right of all the
stories you've done over decades and
decades this one has really gone
worldwide the backyard alien yes oh it's
crazy it's crazy how much email we get
you know uh we're not done with it we'll
see we're going to say this is not the
last of that story no no all right
George thanks for that now